hey it's gone YouTube aeyden
woke up finest in the earth tomorrow huh
ain't nothing I'll tell me that's a
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you may I would told you
though we all did
what is going on you to the job no it is
the end of the world tomorrow envy
speech huh
again cuz I didn't know then y'all told
me - be honest mistake it I cannot be
the only one on this earth there's time
to hearing the [ __ ] I need y'all
understand something
this ain't of love this is a PSA a
public service announcement for you dumb
ass [ __ ] that's right [ __ ]
it's a piss piss piss off of them
goddamn we all know for a lot of
different reasons there are always
specific types of people that always
think the world's gonna end so if you
think there's a nwalalae space and you
just might need this PSA let's get if
you think the world is gonna end
you're usually dumbest [ __ ] y'all ever
noticed the ones that always think the
world's gonna end
were the dumbest people you knew going
up posting all the [ __ ] on Facebook oh
[ __ ] up and turn somebody now here you
[ __ ] please don't character what
makes you think that you are a reputable
source for knowing when the world's
gonna end
mmm this is dude I know right now that
was posting them all the [ __ ] on
Facebook about all the signs of the
Apocalypse my [ __ ] I knew you in high
school you were the only one in school
they got smiley faces on papers instead
of actual grades look mama I got me some
smiley face imagine a blog about this
[ __ ] last yeah I do to get hey let me
take some hey hey [ __ ] the Mayans all
hey tell me what's under your calendar
ends and I got that huh
hell with you maybe the dude that was
making the calendar that [ __ ] tired
of making this [ __ ] by hand and quit his
job first one you know what I won't do
the shared model I've been doing this
[ __ ] begin [ __ ] [ __ ] I died go follow
my dreams
go weave baskets me pay if you think the
world's gonna end you might be all this
fun old people are the ones that are
worried about the most when you people
should be the ones they're worried about
the least you're like at the gym years
old man you live you're done Healthcare
is old as hell huge religious leader had
predicted the world was going to end
twice May 21st of last year and on 1994
when it didn't happen this will backs up
and says well I miscalculated it and
it's actually going to happen at another
time lookie here
no disrespect I'm pretty sure you've
done a lot for the religious community
but let me tell you something you don't
need to stop predicting when the world's
gonna end cuz obviously you don't know
[ __ ] I saw an interview of this dude and
this fool looked lost as hell like he
misplaced his words and he was trying to
find in his head the whole time homes at
home if you're 87 years old are you
talking about I got so much more to do
with my life what monami gonna get your
ass on a tee with that mess Hey look at
me you're a head change okay 80 some
years old alright I still don't have a
suspect and I still can't speak it out
of your language hey you gotta the
cinema yeah I don't even know what the
[ __ ] I'm saying
my grandfather is 95 years old he's not
preparing for the end of the world you
know what he's doing he's working out to
live another day so in your face [ __ ]
look all I'm saying is if you ever climb
Mount Everest by now you need to let
that dream go you need to do is take
bigger steps why don't you walk into a
bathtub first without looking like Bambi
taking the first steps [ __ ] if you think
is there in the world you probably
miserable as hell why because you're
self-deprecating at least you got
nothing to look forward to man what's
wrong with you
just because you're not happy with your
life doesn't me the whole world I am
with you
but to [ __ ] all your guys on a sudden
bit more lemon Java knows that these
same people go on the internet every day
justify the reason why the world's gonna
end and consequently those people happen
to be stupid as hell going to the
supermarket and Costco buying everything
for Armageddon your dumb [ __ ] this ain't
watching Kate said that is the end of
the earth what makes you think they do
survive and the whole world's on the dot
huh selfish [ __ ] everybody in America
is freaked out and said let me tell you
something Asian people don't believe in
that [ __ ]
we're culturally skeptical as hell
unless a dragon or a puff of smoke from
a piece of pipe comes out and tells me
at the end of the earth
it ain't gonna happen hey change did you
hear the world's gonna end
oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] don't like me I wait
for that dragon to tell me later
oh and on another I just found out
through a text message that apparently
psy is a symbol for the world on end huh
how the [ __ ] you don't blame a fat
korean on the [ __ ] I find it highly
offensive
you know what I'll know if it's the end
of the world who cares everybody's gonna
die with you anyways let's you say it is
the end earth I'm as well just do
something that I wanted more well my god
therefore I'm sorry hey Rhonda it was a
mummy it's me David anyhow is there
anything you know you want you and me
just what what [ __ ] myself
[ __ ] hi you don't up you gonna stand or
you will die anyways
feel good right yeah